[Music]
all right check this out an illinois man
let his twin brother serve 20 years in
prison
before finally admitting he was actually
the real kid what the [ __ ]
he led his brother
he [ __ ] what though
20 years wow
you know what i'm like i'm like 80
something now i guess i lived a good
full life
i could come clean you know who actually
did it it was me
so here's the here's the twins right
here oh they're twins yeah dude so his
brother knew it was his dad so [ __ ]
is it because a dna match because
they're twins i it could be or they just
[ __ ] look the same in that i thought
[ __ ] twins got that [ __ ] yeah there
wasn't one of the twin those other ones
[ __ ] lying and [ __ ] maybe it wasn't a
dna thing maybe it was just like a you
know like
a line up you know what i mean and
they're just like oh it's that one for
sure
she's like that's [ __ ] him
yeah it could have been or it's like one
of those things where everyone wishes
they had a clone and twins they do so
it's like it's cool my clone gets to do
that while i get to live my life yeah
sometimes like you know the twin just
like eats the other one inside the belly
but like this is just like an outside of
the belly version
oh man so these twins they um have
different first and last names one of
them's kevin dugard the other guy is
carl smith
uh kevin dugar is the guy that's in jail
and uh he was convicted of a
gang-related killing in 2003
and um he was sentenced to 54 years in
prison but he maintained that he was
innocent the whole time he's like i
didn't do it i didn't do it did he ever
say it was a twin brother and everyone
was like yeah we heard that you probably
you might even know who yeah
yeah nice that's where it gets a little
complicated right because you probably
you think oh he probably didn't know
that's what i thought but the twin thing
you know right because they got the they
got the they got the twin up link yeah
yeah i do they got the freaking lan
connections maybe not having the same
last name kind of disconnected
disconnected the router yeah you know it
makes a lot of sense it ruins the
connection a little bit you know yeah
something about the what the freaking
wpa key yeah what about the password
it's like when you change the password
to your modem and [ __ ] and then like
when you used to connect there and you
go to your friend's house and you're
like yo what happened to the passwords
like i changed it so that's what the
last name does sorry i wish you a
scientist on the show sometimes because
i might as i have these kinds of
questions but then i don't know how it
works 5g keeps you covered anyways yeah
it's true all right i believe uh so so
what happens is smith the guy who the
twin who's not in jail writes him a
letter about a decade later and he says
i have to get it off my chest before it
kills me so i'll just come clean and
pray you can forgive me
and uh then he signs a sworn statement
confessing to the crime and he contacts
his twins lawyers wow he never even
visited him in jail so is he going to
switch a round now is he going to prison
while his
brother gets out yeah it gets even
better yeah because in um does his
brother get to sue the state now so
three years after his confession
and 13 after his twins conviction he
said to a judge i'm here to confess to a
crime that i committed that dugar was
wrongly accused of
but
the retrial was refused
because
the confession came at a time where
smith
was also serving a 99-year sentence
himself oh
so they're thinking you have nothing to
[ __ ] lose
that's why he was doing it yeah
he's like hmm trade the 90 years for 15.
let me go this one actually i did that
yeah that's what they he's releasing his
brother so he could take the fall that's
another way of looking at it who knows
damn in the beginning you had me there i
was like you [ __ ] back and now i'm like
you honorable son of a [ __ ] now that's
the twin connection that is the router
is not this way i think [ __ ] is still
part of it though no i think it's come
here than ever i think so what do you
think so this 99-year sentence guy you
think he's telling the truth
the twin who's saying that oh it was me
that did it let him out you think he's
when did he get the 99 year sentence all
right here's what he got at four i'll
tell you that um
he was convicted uh
after a home invasion ended with a
six-year-old child being shot in the
head oh
wow
he's not honorable you want to take that
guy's word
so twins the twin connections like one
guy murders the other guy murders too i
guess oh wait is the 99
the guy already in jail
oh so he committed another crime yeah a
burglar he had his own [ __ ] a burglary
and a kid got killed in that yeah so
that's a separate thing he got indicted
that's a separate thing the six-year-old
child being shot in the head he's he's
serving 99-year cents for that and then
um we're confused both of them are
criminals both well both of them are
criminals in the system
but one of them saying that he did all
the crime and that guy didn't do
anything and the guy who quote unquote
didn't do anything has also maintained
that he was innocent the entirety of the
time while his twin brother
killed potentially more than one person
and also here comes here comes
everyone's favorite uh thing
so the mom
says
i don't know smith wouldn't lie about
that
[Laughter]
moms are the best man moms man so she's
pretty much saying that really one of
her son actually is innocent and one is
just evil
yeah which one is the one in jail
against smith technically both dugard
which one's in jail right now smith is
the douche bag they're both in jail but
for different things do guard smith
killed a kid and probably killed which
one was the one first wrongly wrongly
oh okay okay okay so smith is coming out
now and saying actually dugard never did
it was me yeah but it's conveniently
that he has another crime that he's okay
but then he still could get his brother
off the case though because i thought
dugard was the one serving a double
crime but but the system or the
judiciary system is saying his lines are
just trying to get his brother off the
hook but then here's what happens next
so the the judge decided to um he
refused that retrial but the decision to
refuse it was appealed by the center on
wrongful convictions at northwestern
university and after re-examination
dugarr was released from cook county
jail wow in chicago so he's out and his
lawyer ronald safer said he is overjoyed
to be free but is also adjusting to a
world that is quite different from the
world he left 20 years ago when he was
arrested for this crime he did not
commit why did he even let his brother
take the fall on the floor colvid too
out of all the time for that many years
how much so uh he got dugard got
convicted first and then smith got
convicted later for his crime afterwards
okay seems like uh yeah so he's probably
already serving like a good amount of
years and then he got popped for
something else he did half his time do
you so so so he went during y2k he
thought the world was going to end with
the computers but it didn't right
and then now he comes out during [ __ ]
covey
like that's crazy lot has man a lot has
changed that i don't know damn that is a
different word what do you think the
odds are that that twins that one of
them is like a crazy-ass criminal the
other guy's completely innocent like one
is the angel one is the devil like a yin
and yang i feel like
very low yeah well i think
i think this one makes sense so if they
had two different last names i'm
assuming they had two different dads so
they actually had two different
upbringings so this is like a case of
like nature versus nurture
where like the nurture really kind of
like
spread their destinies versus most twins
same genetics and also very similar
upbringing so they end up you know going
to the same places you know i know some
twins
hold this knife i says i know some twins
that got into a uh like a house party
fight and then uh ended up um there was
a stabbing that occurred but because
they were twins and they wouldn't uh one
wouldn't rat the other one out
the courts never were able to identify
which one did it so they each split one
sentence
so one once i think was like an eight
year sentence and then like one went in
for like four years came out and then
the other one went in for the next four
years
so if you're at a house party and you're
a twin and you're getting your ass beat
in a room is the other twin just in
another room and he's just awesome he's
getting his ass beat
because he's like making out with the
girls
he's feeling all the hits like the
matrix he's just sitting there
yeah yeah he's sleeping that's how it
works right the guy getting his ass
beats also having like some kind of
sexual feelings from whatever the other
guy is doing oh yeah so he gets his ass
beat and he comes oh
it's confusing for both sides
why are you coming that's okay stop
coming i'm coming
[Laughter]
that means the innocent twin
is actually really down yeah like he's
like [ __ ] it i'll serve half of it yeah
even though i didn't do [ __ ] well maybe
they didn't actually commit the moment
but they were in the brawl
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's wow that's crazy or maybe
they held together and said twins
combine their forces yeah they're both
each holding the same knife
dude if you're a twin and your twin dies
do you just like turn to your family and
you're like bye and then you fade away
no it's like it's like back to the
future where you're playing on stage
your hand just slowly disappears your
head starts
getting transparent twin [ __ ] freaks me
out dude that's crazy about triplets one
dies and then the other two they're
uplink it's stronger no they're 80
opacity if i have twins i'm gonna teach
them to speak in sync all the time
like those horror movies
dress them the same way and then they
can speak straight faced here yeah they
don't speak together but they like say
one word at a time to say the sentence
and it's like perfectly seamless do you
guys have uh twins in any other families
no but the best twin prank you could
ever do so when they're born and they're
laying there next to each other you
[ __ ] put them in the same outfit and
you shuffle them up a couple times and
then that's it
parents won't have any [ __ ] idea
which ones that's true that's how you do
twin pranks dude you do it at the
hospital
they go the rest of their lives being
switched is there a scientific way to
fully identify who's who like uh
you can't
i thought they both had the same styles
yeah
there's no other so like if uh
if like let's say there was a fire and
twins died you wouldn't be able to
identify the [ __ ] oh wow yeah i don't
think so no unless one of them should
have different dental records
as a guest dude did you ever see that
documentary about those triplets got
split up yeah in a science experiment
they grew up in all different uh in a
science experience and it was revealed
way later that it was this [ __ ]
experiment that they didn't even know
that's the biggest it was just the prank
bro i've ever heard so it's a social
experience it's a social experiment and
these scientists would go to their house
and visit them like periodically and
these kids they grew up thinking it's
uncle bob being visited yeah but they
were being visited for [ __ ] progress
report to see if nature versus nurture
was really like true why don't we have
cool science like that anymore i think
it's because it's cruel
did you say cruel science or cool
science cool science yeah you should you
need to change that r and the u and the
e and make it
cool
this will work for the three o's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you